لم يتم رؤيتهم أو سماع إطلاق نار إلا
بمجرد أن تقوم أهدافهم بإسقاط
وحدة النخبة الأوكرانية للقناصة من
الأجهزة الأمنية، عادة ما تكون قوات الأمن الأوكرانية
غير مرئية
مثل قوة دلتا الأمريكية التي تم اختيارها من أجل
اللياقة والاستخبارات على عكس
قتال دلتا من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة في وطنهم لمدة
18 شهرًا تقريبًا التي
قدموها  مقابلة نادرة مع شبكة سي إن إن أثناء قيامهم بصقل مناظير
القناصة الخاصة بهم
لبث الضرر الذي يقولون إنهم
يلحقونه بالخطوط الأمامية الروسية،
إنه إرهاب القناصة، حيث يقول إنه عندما
نضرب كل هدف نرصده، فإن ذلك
يحبط معنوياتهم ويقتل إرادتهم
لفعل أي شيء ضدنا
قبل خمسة أسابيع، عثروا ليلاً على
جثة مجموعة ريكون روسية،
كنا في المنطقة الرمادية بين
خطوطنا، كما يقول القائد باستخدام دليل
من وحدة أخرى، لكننا واجهنا
مجموعة هجومية روسية تقوم إلى حد كبير بما حدث.
نفس الشيء عندما كنا نتحرك نحو
موقعنا الأمامي، فتحنا النار وأصيب مرشدنا وقمنا بقمعهم وأخرجناه
بالمدفعية ثم
شاهدناهم يتراجعون مع جرحاهم
[موسيقى]
إنهم لا يهربون دائمًا، يعلم ساشا
ذلك جيدًا لقد  يقول: لقد فقدنا العديد من الأشخاص،
أفضلهم يغادروننا أولاً، وقد طويت
شفته العليا قليلاً بسبب
الإصابة عندما أصابت قذيفة كبيرة
صدره وساقيه ووجهه في مارس الماضي،
كان الأمر مزعجًا، لكني أجريت 16
عملية لإعادة بناء عظامي وأسناني
وأنا  لقد عادوا إلى القتال،
فالمساعدة الغربية أبقتهم واقفة على قدميها، كما
يقولون، بندقية قنص باريت المضادة للدروع، وهي
تبرع يتم استخدامه كثيرًا لدرجة أن كاتم الصوت
قد انفك ويربط
هذه الآلات والرجال الذين
يعملون في تيمبو ربما
لم يكونوا مصممين لأنهم يعرفون السبب  إنهم
هنا على الرغم من أن ابني يكبر.
يقول ساشا إنه صغير ولكنه يتدرب بالفعل
ويعرف بالفعل من هو العدو
وهو روسيا،
وتأمل كل طلقة أن تقرب الهزيمة الروسية